tres emergencias climáticas y una sola
tierra el calentamiento global la
pérdida de especies y la contaminación
acechan al planeta en el día mundial del
medioambiente la onu recalca que el 67
por ciento de las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero están asociadas a
nuestro estilo de vida uno que
contribuye a que el planeta se caliente
a un ritmo demasiado rápido para que las
personas y la naturaleza se adapten un
medioambiente degradado que tiene
consecuencias en nuestra salud
la contaminación es responsable de unos
9 millones de muertes prematuras cada
año y según the lancet en 2019 causó una
de cada 6 muertes en el mundo esto es
más que las cifras anuales de muertes
debido a la guerra las drogas y el
alcohol otra alarma las zonas de peligro
climático cerca del 50% de la población
mundial vive en esos lugares donde tiene
15 veces más probabilidades de morir a
causa de los impactos climáticos y según
la onu para 2050 más de 200 millones de
personas cada año correrán el riesgo de
ser desplazadas debido a la alteración
del clima la fauna y la flora también
son las grandes afectadas más de un
millón de especies de plantas y de
animales corren el riesgo de que
unos datos que alarman y un objetivo
mundial que sale a relucir el de limitar
el calentamiento global a 15 grados
centígrados para alcanzarlo la onu
asegura que debemos reducir a la mitad
las emisiones anuales de gases de efecto
invernadero para 2030